ننشر الأخبار العاجلة الليلة عن
عملية البحث واسعة النطاق للعثور على تلك
الغواصة التي كان على متنها خمسة أشخاص
والتي فُقدت يوم الأحد أثناء رحلة
لمشاهدة حطام السفينة تيتانيك،
هناك تطور جديد في الساعة الماضية يُقال إن أطقم
البحث عن الغواصة
سمعت اليوم  أصوات ضجيج على فترات كل 30 دقيقة،
ثم بعد
نشر أجهزة السونار الإضافية، استمر
سماع ضجيج، حسنًا، هذا وفقًا
لمذكرة داخلية للحكومة الأمريكية،
ولم يكن من الواضح بالضبط متى
تم سماع هذا الضجيج، ويشير التحديث اللاحق الذي تم إرساله
الليلة إلى سماع المزيد من الأصوات
على الرغم من أنها كانت  لا يوصف بأنه
ضجيج أريد إحضار
مستكشف أعماق البحار وعالم المحيطات ديفيد جالو
ديفيد شكرًا جزيلاً لك على وجودك هنا.
ما الذي يخبرك به هذا التطور
حسنًا، إنه على الفور أول شيء هو
أنه يرفع آمالك بشكل كبير
ولكنه أيضًا يجعلك تفكر  هذا رائع، كما
تعلم أن الوقت الآن ضدنا حقًا، لذا فهو
يشجعك حقًا على القيام بشيء ما ولكن
افعله بسرعة لأنك
تعلم على أي حال أنه يجب عليك أن تكون
هناك القليل من الحذر هنا
لأنه إذا كنت عضوًا في الخطوط
الجوية الماليزية، فقد كانت هناك  كل أنواع الضجيج والصفير والملوثات العضوية الثابتة التي
سمعتها كانت
إيجابية هذا أو ذاك وتبين أنها ليست
أيًا من هذه الأشياء، أنا لا
أستبعد هذا ولكن نعم، إنه يرفع
آمال العائلات والأحباء،
وهو يفعل ذلك  تسبب تفاؤلاً فيما
يتعلق بدعونا نبدأ هذا العرض،
لذا فأنا أنظر إليه
كعلامة إيجابية للغاية والآن السؤال التالي
هو كيف نكتشف ذلك وكيف
نتحقق على الفور
ماذا عن ماذا عن  كل 30
دقيقة بماذا يخبرك ذلك،
لا أعلم أنك تعلم أنني أفكر في الرقم الهيدروجيني يا
عزيزي، وأقرب أصدقائي وزميلي
موجود في تلك الغواصة وهو يعرف
ما يفعله وربما اكتشف
أن هذا هو  أفضل طريقة لجعلهم
يتعرفون على مكان موت الهواء